Russian President Vladimir Putin has
offered political asylum to former FBI
director James Comey saying that he's
fearful that James Comey is going to be
prosecuted in the United States Comey
was of course the director of the FBI
until he was fired by our president
Donald Trump who was explicit more than
once about having fired Comey for
reasons related to the FBI's
investigation into ties between Russia
and the Trump campaign then Comey
testified before the Senate calling
Trump a liar numerous times
even though Russia has been providing
asylum to NSA leaker Edward Snowden for
the past four years this is one of
commis expert I'm sorry one of Putin's
expert trolling tongue-in-cheek power
plays almost nothing that Putin says or
does in public is sincere and it's
usually flexing muscles and he's also of
course trying to suggest that the u.s.
is corrupt which in some ways it is and
of course in many ways Russia is also
corrupt here is Vladimir Putin on
television during during an event
talking about this and then we'll go
through the translation piece-by-piece
non-smokers cut off to gnaw on vita-self
gave osprey giddy anthem a pituitary
swivel druga result algorithm a swing
pharmacy no a tourism which is religious
tremana candle quality spits wood that
is later gab or
raccoon am colonic evaluation a Potomac
cheese waver droga trader it's me I can
tag the being self-aware appreciates
what
páginas northerner but down near go a
little speed soothe one Pradesh
significative
vitiated a poppy Dylan nap little new
pilots
special relativity sweetie poor Jeff
nibbles abrasion catechism pre-press a
donor egg nickelsburg Dalia my EMU gotta
be Impreza state politics to be racial
races on those on the bottom tonight so
let's start with the first part of this
okay
Vladimir Putin saying Comey said he'd
written down his conversation with
President Trump and handed it to the
media through a friend of his
this does sound and look odd the
director of a national
security service making records of his
talks with the Supreme Commander and
handing it over to the media through a
friend of his
Putin can't believe that other leaders
let this type of thing go on or that a
political system could even allow this
type of thing to go on there's no chance
that Comey is actually going to be
prosecuted in the United States for
political reasons I think this is one of
those situations where Putin distaste
for the US is overriding his possible
admiration of Trump as a tool that he
can use not that he finds Trump to be
personally a great guy or smart or
anything like that maybe it's for optics
maybe Putin is trying to distance
himself from Trump and maybe throw
people off then Putin went on to say
quote it makes him not a security
service director but a civil activist
advocating a certain belief that quote
makes me think Putin is just trying to
make Comey look bad maybe that's what
this is all about and then he added this
key line of the entire thing by the way
if he faces any kind of prosecution in
this regard we will provide political
asylum in Russia for him as well he
should be aware of that Putin is a
brilliant political satirist I mean not
even the onion could come up with
something like this this is one of the
greatest trolls Milo you novelists is
put to shame by the trolling prowess of
Vladimir Putin I mean there's this idea
by many that James Comey did something
wrong by leaking his notes about his
meeting with Donald Trump right not as
if that was classified or he did
anything illegal there you can leak
whatever words you said no doubt about
it
no doubt about it and Vladimir Putin
even though saying here that he would
provide asylum for James Comey if
necessary simultaneously a brutal of
pressure of a presser of free speech
imagine if Comey went to Russia
I hope Comey wouldn't slip down the
stairs and fall on a bunch of bullets I
mean sometimes if there's just a bunch
of bullets lying at the bottom of the
stairs it's really easy to fall on them
especially for former American
intelligence officers or you know end up
falling onto a knife several times and
from different angles and then turning
around and maybe falling onto onto the
knife with your back or something like
that these horrible thing
can happen he seems like a healthy guy
but if he just all of a sudden drops
dead of a heart attack that's just what
happened it's a risk that that we've
seen unfortunately and we're kind of
joking but it is brutal what has
happened to many dissidents in and
around the Putin regime today's episode
of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass or the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS